c'est l'heure de notre débat 100%
politique dans ce sens public les quatre
principaux mouvements et représentants
parlement vont confronter leurs
propositions en matière de pouvoir
d'achat c'est le texte évidemment le
plus attendu par les français que nous
attendons tous avec comme base de
discussion le projet présenté
aujourd'hui en conseil des ministres
fabien becker pour aider les français
face à l'inflation le gouvernement des
voix de ses propositions avec en
particulier un volet énergie mise en
place à l'automne le plafonnement des
prix du gaz et de l'électricité est
prolongé jusqu'à la fin de l'année
prolonger aussi la remise de 18 centimes
par litre de carburant
mais celle ci doit baisser
progressivement et être remplacé par une
aide carburant pour les travailleurs
sous conditions de ressources on doit
maintenant s'engager dans une mesure
plus ciblées quel est le choix politique
très politique que nous faisons soutenir
ceux qui travaillent le salarié qui va
son entreprise il doit pas avoir de
problèmes pour faire son plein
l'alternant qui doit se rendre son
entreprise et qui habite encore chez ses
parents il ne doit pas avoir de
problèmes pour financer son plein autres
mesures pour augmenter le pouvoir
d'achat le triplement du plafond de la
prime macron versées par les employeurs
ainsi qu'un chèque alimentaires de 100
euros destinés à neuf millions de foyers
son montant pourrait augmenter en
fonction du nombre d'enfants à charge
pour se rapprocher du niveau de
l'inflation prestations sociales et
pensions de retraite doivent augmenter
de 4% les salaires des fonctionnaires
sont revalorisés de trois et demi pour
cent c'est trois et demi pour cent
d'augmentation et concerne tous les
agents de la fonction publique tous les
agents des trois versants fonctionnaires
comme contractuels on va le traduire
dans les logiciels de paie sur les
fiches de paie le plus rapidement
possible sur le front du logement enfin
le texte plafonne la hausse des loyers à
trois et demi pour cent et augmente les
apl dans les mêmes proportions toutes
ces propositions doivent maintenant être
débattu à l'assemblée à partir du 18
juillet et j'ouvre ce débat tout de
suite en vous présentant mes invités
aurélie trouvé où on soir bienvenus
député la france insoumise de seine
saint denis et membre du groupe new baby
damman à l'assemblée julien oudoul
bonsoir bien vous êtes député
rassemblement national de l'yonne porte
parole du rnd également jean françois
husson bonsoir c'est même ça va elle est
de meurthe-et-moselle rapporteur général
de la commission des finances eric
delannoy économiste président fondateur
du cabinet tenzing et vous étiez
référent économie c'est ça c'était le
terme exact sur la travail sur la dans
la campagne sur le programme de prêts en
ciel des manuels macron je démarre avec
donc que ce projet de loi présenté en
conseil des ministres indemnités
carburant pour les travailleurs jusqu'à
300 euros le chèque alimentation la
revalorisation du point d'indicé pour
les fonctionnaires à trois et demi
question de blocage des loyers etc etc
est ce que vous le rejeter en bloc ou
est ce que vous dites y'a quand même
comme disait un ancien leader syndical
du grain à moudre ben on leur jette
surtout la philosophie derrière tout ça
parce que le problème c'est que le
gouvernement refuse de proposer les deux
mesures essentielles pour s'attaquer aux
causes de l'inflation 1 le blocage des
prix des produits de première nécessité
seule façon de s'en prendre en fait à la
part des profits qui nourrit qui nourrit
l'inflation en réalité l'inflation est
surtout nourrie par les profits et pas
par les salaires donc pour bloquer ça il
faut bloquer les prix des produits de
première nécessité ce qui va permettre
aux plus précaires qui sont ceux qui
souffrent le plus de par exemple de
l'augmentation du prix du paquet de
pâtes et bien de s'en sortir et puis
deuxième mesure essentielle c'est la
hausse des salaires réels je rappelle
qu'il y à beaucoup plus d'inflation de
montée des prix que de hausses des
salaires donc il ya une perte de salaire
réel il est urgent d'augmenter les
salaires réels en commençant par
l'augmentation du smic évidemment élan
c'est quand on augmente le smic en fait
on augmente l'ensemble des bas salaires
évidemment je lis ou 12
marine le pen elle a redit ce matin dans
une interview radio elle elle dit
refuser obstruction systématique est ce
que le rn pourraient voter ce texte en
l'état ou participer aux amendements
pour l'améliorer éventuellement vous
savez notre boussole menant avant qu'une
c'est l'intérêt de la france et des
français est depuis de nombreux mois on
voit des millions de français qui
souffrent de la précarité qui souffrent
de l'inflation qui aujourd'hui les
asphyxier au quotidien n'arrive plus à
se déplacer il n'arrête plus même à se
nourrir pour certains d'entre eux on
voyait que le travail ne rémunère plus
que certains d'ailleurs se mettre en
arrêt maladie parce que ça coûte trop
cher d'aller à son travail de mettre de
l'essence dans sa voiture donc la
situation est tellement grave tellement
urgente que il faut qu'il y ait des
décisions qui soient prises donc nous
allons regarder sérieusement sereinement
ce texte nous allons l'amendé parce que
nous avons des propositions extrêmement
concrètes que nous jugeons pertinentes
notamment la baisse de la tva sur les
produits énergétiques proposition phare
de marine le pen mais nous ne rejetons
pas tout en bloc parce que même si des
propositions sont insuffisantes
même si elles ne sont pas parfaites et
évidemment qu'elles ne sont pas
parfaites puisque les propositions du
gouvernement nous espérons d'ailleurs
que le gouvernement ait un changement de
méthode qui est une capacité d'écouté
qui et j'allais dire une appréciation
des propositions qui viennent de
l'opposition quand même si les abeilles
mort les éditions sont insuffisantes et
qu'elle apporte un petit peu d'air un
petit peu dead à des millions de
français qui souffrent évidemment que
nous allons les soutenir parce que nous
encore une fois nous sommes élus pour le
peuple se met lui pour le défendre et
nous sommes élus surtout pour les aider
dans une situation qui est extrêmement
difficile de ne pas retarder
indéfiniment ce le vote de ce texte est
ce que vous êtes prêts à co construire
jean françois husson un texte sur le
pouvoir d'achat
j'ai écouté avec attention l'opération
séduction hier de la première ministre
elisabeth bornes pour tout vous dire
le sénat a écouté avec attention et
c'est toujours agréable d'avoir des
propos de séduction des des propos
laudateurs
de la première ministre qui tu démarres
son action et qui vient finalement un
peu qu'on fait c'est
la rigueur la radicalité la verticalité
que le pouvoir exécutif depuis cinq ans
a eu dans son rapport aux élus aux
territoires et aux corps intermédiaires
ensuite
hier j'ai eu plutôt comment dire et j'ai
le sentiment que c'était un peu
la merde ol qui venait avec beaucoup de
belles décision de belles intentions
sans mettre le début du commencement de
quelques additions qui combien ça coûte
et c'est quoi votre console avoue c910
seul lors d'achats notre boussole c'est
simple c'est un esprit de responsabilité
un redressement des comptes et une
attention donnée à celles et ceux qui
ont le plus besoin
quelles sont celles et ceux dont il faut
cibler les mesures et bien sûr c'est
tout simplement ce que j'avais dit dans
les dernières intentions que j'ai fait
j'avais d'ailleurs dénoncé l'absence de
ciblage de l'un des mythes inflation
alors on s'était fait balayer d'un
revers de main il arrive exactement ce
que la mise en garde aujourd'hui le
gouvernement est en train finalement de
fait à un acte de contrition
eric delannoy je disais en présentation
tout à l'heure que on est sur une ligne
de crête et on l'a entendu avec les
propos de
de bruno le maire et après trois mille
milliards de dette il ya bien un moment
où il va falloir arrêter le quoi qu'il
en coûte peut-être dans ce pays donc
sauf que là il ya une urgence et une
urgence effectivement pour des millions
de français et notamment pour ceux qui
sont dans les situations les plus
précaires donner une mauvaise habitude
dans ce pays à faire entendre à chaque à
chaque problème il y ait une solution de
court terme de court terme et c'est bien
ça le problème c'est qu'on a que des
solutions de court terme ont fait des
chèques on distribue ceux ci ont des
tripes cela s'est jamais assez pour les
uns avec une forme de de mon point de
vue de vision misérabiliste de la
société française nous sommes dans une
urgence on se croit grimper une
tiers-monde
il y en a il y en a il y en a c'est
c'est trop pour les autres parce qu'il
faut revenir une rigueur budgétaire donc
on est bien sur une ligne de crête qui
est très compliqué à tenir moi je suis
d'accord sur le fait que la seule
manière de traiter le problème
économique de l'inflation aujourd'hui
c'est de cibler les aides voilà pourquoi
c'est pourquoi pour une raison
extrêmement simple c'est que nous avons
un choc d'offre un choc d'offre ça veut
dire que les que le prix des produits
vendus augmente parce que les matières
premières augmentent tous d'accord et
que c'est ce que le problème des
matières premières qui augmente c'est
malheureusement ces facteurs exogènes et
que derrière on n'arrive pas à en
produire suffisamment on n'arrive pas en
produire suffisamment et on n'arrive pas
en choisir sur lié au fait de la suite
ducobu donc sa première choc d'offre ça
veut dire que les prix effectivement
augmente si demain alors que on a
distribué beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent c'est donc minces et s'étonnant
tout le monde oublie ça on a distribué
plus de 200 milliards dans son schéma
milliards pendant la crise du coc vide
où les pouvoirs dachau et et sauvegarder
le pouvoir d'achat augmenter pendant
quatre ans ce qui n'était pas arrivé
depuis 20 ans c'est l'essai pivot vie
dans sa facilité qui
sévit dans les périodes aussi plus
simplement cédé fait céder fait ça donc
donc aujourd'hui on les styles l'insee
estime qu'avec l'inflation qui existe le
pouvoir d'achat a baissé de 1% en 2000
22 1% exki les aides sont qui sont
prévues là et on crie au scandale quoi
fin à un moment par contre la note qui
va y avoir sur le sur la dette et sur le
quoi qu'il en coûte il faut je vais
arrêter par exemple en est puisque
aurélie trouvé blocage des prix aux néo
salaire réel qu'est ce que le blocage
des prix c'est l'archétype de la
mauvaise solution parce qu'on sent bien
qu'il y a des solutions très facile à
exprimer mais qui ne tiennent pas compte
d'un effet systémique de la mesure
blocage des prix vous dire quoi veut
dire que quelqu'un qui voit ses matières
premières augmentent et ne va pas
pouvoir augmenter ses prix d'avoir
débloqué donc ça veut dire qu'il va y
avoir un resserrement des marges
considérables voire même un déficit sur
les matières premières dont on sait que
les marges sur ses produits y sont
traditionnellement faibles et donc vous
allez vous avoir simplement des
entreprises qui vont péricliter etc et
donc du chômage
chômage la maison qui se trouve monsieur
vous êtes économiste mais je suis de
jusqu'à et quelques jours j'étais maître
de conférences en économie est
d'ailleurs fonctionnaire je leur parle
et ça tombe bien d'abord sur la
responsabilité et la question de la
dette publique en l'occurrence les cinq
ans du quinquennat avait été une
catastrophe puisque la dette publique a
augmenté de 600 milliards d'euros pour
des mauvaises dépenses en l'occurrence
pour verser des aides massives aux
entreprises qui ont surtout sans
condition qui ont surtout servi à
augmenter les dividendes à faire
exploser par deux multiplication par
deux des 500 plus grandes fortunes
explosion des dividendes du cac 40 est
notamment de total qui augmente ses
dividendes de 16 milliards d'euros
l'année dernière et j'en arrive à la
question du blocage des prix parce que
par exemple bloquer le prix de l'essence
à 1 euros 40 qui était le niveau de
janvier 2021 revient justement à bloquer
les profits que ce fonds ce type de
multinationales et ensuite sur les
dépenses il faut évidemment des dépenses
utiles qui répondent aux besoins des
français par ce qui a été fait par une
politique de l'offre la preuve le
premier problème des entreprises le
premier problème vous regardez toutes
les enquêtes qui sont faites notamment
du ministère du travail les premiers le
premier problème des entreprises c'est
le carnet de commandes donc il faut
relancer la consommation populaire et ça
passe par quoi ça passe par la hausse
des salaires réels ça passe par la
hausse des minima sociaux est bien plus
que ce qui est prévu par exemple la
hausse
là on dit ah oui on va déjeuner lundi ce
n'est fonctionnaires il augmentez trois
et demi pour cent l'inflation elle et 2
5% ça veut dire qu'en fait on prévoit
une baisse des salaires des
fonctionnaires puisque donc on au nombre
de trois et demi trois et demi pour cent
pour les fonctionnaires vous dites s'est
passé il ya sur ce point précis moi
j'essaie de m'accrocher à des stades et
à des propositions précises des dessins
et des autres est ce que vous en pensez
jean françois husson c'est enfin
j'imagine que le programme de la nuque
en matière de pouvoir d'achat pourra
vous aider en temps mais le pouvoir de
le programme de la dupe c'est pas ni ni
matin ni midi ni soir enfin le parce que
si vous voulez on promet tout on rase
gratis
évidemment ça fait plaisir on ne
s'arrête il ya plus de bornes
aujourd'hui on est dans un monde d'hier
et dans une france des pénuries pénurie
de ressources pénurie de main-d'oeuvre
et pénurie de matières premières enfin
tout ça s'est passé en moins de deux ans
comment on répond à ça mais je pense
qu'il faut prioritairement créer de la
richesse comment crée-t-on de la
richesse en revalorisant le travail en
défiscalisant les heures supplémentaires
en facilitant le temps de travail pour
recréer de la richesse et en
accompagnant celles et ceux qui sont
encore en dehors du marché du travail
par de la formation en les rendant
comment dirais-je opérationnel pour
qu'il soit actif parce que je préfère
une france des actifs une qu'une france
de personnes qui aujourd'hui
malheureusement sont éloignées du monde
du travail le travail c'est pas une
forme d' à cédric d'asservissement c'est
aussi une manière de se réaliser une
manière d'apporter une contribution une
manière de faire france et france
ensemble julien houle ce que j'adore
avec la droite c'est que j'ai toujours
eu l'impression d'entendre le même
disque c'était des discours nicolas
sarkozy c'est formidable vous recycler
les éléments de langage mais en fait
vous n'avez rien fait quand vous étiez
au pouvoir c'est assez formidable c'est
d'ailleurs si vous êtes
% ça s'explique aussi parce que vous
n'avez jamais mis en oeuvre ce que vous
avez présenté et vous voulez mourir a
pas de sujet revenir sur un point sur le
quoi qu'il en coûte comme si on avait
distribué de l'argent c'était
exceptionnel il fallait remercier le
président macro mais excusez moi la
france est la première puissance
quel du monde si les français sont taxés
matin midi et soir il faut bien qu'il ya
un retour sur investissement est
notamment qu'en période de difficultés
en période de crise en période
d'inflation bah oui on aide les plus
précaires donc excusez moi moi ça me
choque pas et ensuite concernant les
efforts parce que il ya bien quelqu'un
qui ne fait pas d'efforts en france
c'est l'état les français font des
efforts au quotidien ils se sont adaptés
à tous à la hausse du prix d'électricité
à la hausse des prix de l'essence enfin
il à la hausse du prix du caddie mais
l'état lui continue de percevoir sa tva
ils taxent matin midi et soir à chaque
passage à la pompe c'est 60% que récolte
l'état et à aucun moment le président
macron où son gouvernement n'ont
l'intention de rendre un petit peu
d'argent et donc de baisser ses profits
et je veux dire excusez moi c'est
goinfrerie parce que plus encore une
fois les carburants explose puis les
énergies augmente et bien effectivement
c'est l'état qui en profite avec la tva
donc nous demandons la mesure la plus
simple la plus claire et surtout la plus
pérenne pour rentrer de l'argent aux
français baisse de la tva de 20% à 5 5
sur toutes les énergies c'est à dire
quoi et transformer en produits de
première nécessité parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est une nécessité d'aller travailler
nécessité de se chauffer de s'éclairer
et accessoirement de se nourrir ça
rendrait 150 euros à 200 euros de
pouvoir d'achat par mois à chaque ménage
alors c'est pas du chèque ponctuelles
parce que le chèque le 100 euros par 600
euros parler de ça j 100 euros c'est un
plan donc une heure vous l'avez perçues
après c'est intéressant on veut
maintenant on a on a
débattu autour de vos propositions on va
débattre maintenant autour de cette
proposition effectivement baisse de la
tva de 20 à 5 5% sur les énergies pour
une première mini site c'est ce qui est
fascinant toujours avec les populistes
et toujours et tout est toujours très
simple en fait il suffit de ça profite à
l'état qui se goinfre mais à quoi sert
la tva qui est la première ressource de
l'état aujourd'hui à quoi sert elle sert
à payer un système de retraite qui est
le plus élevé en europe elle sert à
payer le reste à charge 0 qui a été voté
par emmanuel macron qui permet 10
millions de français de vouloir soigner
alors qu'il ne pouvait pas le faire ça
sert à faire les transferts sociaux je
vous rappelle que parmi ces gens qui
sont dans la misère absolue en france et
y en a qu il faut aider et mon travail
est d'ailleurs c'est pour les aider ce
que vous devez savoir saison qui sont
dans la misère absolue 20 % d'aidés de
ceux qui gagnent le moins en france
perçoit ont une augmentation de leurs
revenus de 75 % grâce aux transferts
sociaux et les 20% de ceux qui gagnent
le plus ont une baisse de leurs revenus
de 20 % pour pouvoir permettre ces
transferts sociaux donc la tva c'est un
sac ça sert donc si vous voulez enlevé
que la tva vous enlever des ressources
et l'état et on remet en cause l'état
leur l'état providence vous qui avez
envie d et les français donc c'est une
mauvaise solution parce qu'elle n'est
pas discriminante la tva alors qu'on la
dit et économique on s'est prouvé on
doit cibler ces aides et il faut que
ceux qui ont les moyens payent c'est du
rafale soit politiquement c'est pas
porter de dire qu'elle est peu des
français qui doivent payer mais je suis
désolé il faut qu'il est je vous
rappelle que pendant lequel à la crise
de coheed il ya eu 175 milliards 2,2
d'epargne qui ont été réalisés et ce
n'est pas les 1% des français qu'ils ont
réalisés ces 25 % des français qui ont
fait cette épargne là avec une moyenne
de dix mille euros eh bien ces gens là
il faut que maintenant ils dépensent et
qu'on ne les aide pas enfin s'il n'y a
pas de raisonner de manière
indifférenciée l'épargné des français
ceux qui ont réussi à l'épargnant donner
la parole juste après mais sur cette
proposition du rassemblement national
baisse de la tva de 20 à 5 était d'abord
je vais répondre à la fin on rase gratis
et que ça parce qu'à chaque fois on
caricature évidemment j'oserais en
l'occurrence le programme d' emmanuel
macron est une caricature d'extrême
ribéry ce que je vois que vous vous le
défendez
services d'accès je vais vous expliquer
sur les chemins libéralisme et que les
mesures visant la baisse des dépenses et
vous l'avez prouvé avec le enfin en tout
cas dans le programme des matchs
battront ils seront bien sûr un effet je
vous ai fait monsieur je ne vous ai pas
coupés mais les séquences et s'est fait
un nom dans ton idée des éléments de
langage qui ne veulent rien dire pardon
mais c'est pareil pas pour dire des
choses comme ça en résine est sur des
propos qui ont sonné le dialogue parce
que moi je navigue chose qui adore la
peur n'est pas plate madame donc allez-y
à l'aise il y aller si la terre n'est
pas voulait bien me laisser parler de la
cie la terre n'est pas plein mais je
vous dis c'est insupportable et les
hommes qui ne sut qui ne laissera pas
les laisser et par
les éoliennes trouver si on sort
démonstration et s'il vous plaît de
l'intérieur ne m'interrompez pas donc
notre programme d'abord puisque vous
dites on rase gratis un programme est
chiffré il a été soutenu par 170
économie scientifiques qui sont parmi
les économistes les plus connus à gauche
de toutes les institutions économiques
les plus prestigieuses de france vous
pouvez regarder on a quatre heures de
quatre heures d'émission de chiffrage
économique et aucun aucune autre force
politique n'a fait n'a fait ce travail
là en l'occurrence qu'on prévoit nous
dans notre programme c'est 250 milliards
servent de recettes de dépenses
supplémentaires mais 265 milliards de
recettes publiques supplémentaires
ensuite sur les recettes publiques ça me
fait rire quand il laisse leçons de
morale de la macro ni parce qu'en
l'occurrence le la loi pouvoir d'achat
l'acquis et qui est proposé elle prévoit
55 milliards de plus de dépenses
pourquoi parce que tous les petits chats
qui vont être faits qui sont des petits
chèques insuffisant et qui en plus
résolvent pas le problème au fond vont
coûter au contribuable et le problème
c'est que vous faites payer justement le
contribuable dans la loi pouvoir d'achat
au lieu de faire payer les vrais
profiteurs de la hausse des prix et les
vrais profiteurs de la hausse des prix
c'est qui ce sont les grands détenteurs
du capital alors ça vous l'avais déjà
dit donc c'est moi qui vous interrompt
cette fois ci je voudrais que vous
répondiez à ma question concernant la
baisse de la tva de vincent bonne ou
mauvaise propos de la baisse de la tva
le problème il est ce si c'est vrai
c'est que une fois encore c'est des
baisses de recettes publiques et donc
c'est les caisses publiques qui prennent
donc nous c'est pour ça qu'on propose
comme mesure phare les deux que je vous
ai dit d'abord la hausse des salaires
réels s'est le plus logique c'est à dire
les salaires ne suivent pas la hausse
des prix donc il faut hausser les
salaires réels en commençant par les
plus bas salaires et deuxièmement le
blocage des prix qui permet de en fait
bloqué les les profils et les marges qui
sont faites dernière chose les
entreprises ont des marges qui ont
atteint ce qu'on appelle un haut
historique c'est à dire que les marges
n'ont jamais été aussi importants dans
les entreprises et notamment les très
grandes entreprises grâce notamment aux
cadeaux fiscaux qui ont été faits sous
la macro ni depuis depuis cinq ans et
est tous les cadeaux fiscaux qui ont été
faits on nourrit en particulier les ces
grandes entreprises et pas les plus
petites c'est bien voulu intervenir oui
je tiens à préciser que la baisse de la
tva sur les énergies ça coûte 12
milliards d'euros par an nous le
finançons très simplement en allant
récupérer sur la fraude sociale sur la
fraude sociale dont on évalue le montant
d'ailleurs c'était un rapport du sénat
entre 15 milliards d'euros jusqu'à 45
milliards d'euros dont vous voyez rien
qu'avec la fourquet riba se lance rien
qu'avec la fourchette basse de la fraude
sociale on finance largement cette
baisse de tva et encore une fois c'est
pas de l'argent qui dilapide et c'est de
l'argent qui est rendu aux français pour
la consommation pour leur permettre de
travailler pour lutter justement pour
qu'il se mette pas en arrêt maladie donc
c'est de l'argent tout simplement qui va
servir l'économie française c'est pas de
l'argent qu'on ait perdu contrairement à
ce qui a été dit mais jean françois
husson vous disiez il nous faut des
mesures ciblées tout à l'heure c'est pas
exactement ce que proposent leurs
annonces c'est une mesure aveugle sans
discernement on ne regarde pas là où il
faut agir et puis j'espère que
l'inflation ne va pas durer je peux le
dire d'autant plus facilement qu'il ya
près d'un ans j'allais retient le
gouverneur de la banque de france sur un
risque d'inflation m'avait dit ça avait
une petite bosse
ne pouvait pas savoir qui on est le
conflit le conflit créé je vous remets
les cheveux fins jambes et l'église au
milieu du village et aucun souci
aujourd'hui il faut des mesures ciblées
est des mesures temporaires et des
mesures temporaires il faut arrêter je
suis déjà je le redis le grand soir on
rase gratis l'argent mais l'argent
public l'argent qui vient des impôts et
donc de l'état
c'est l'argent des français donc on doit
l'utiliser le mieux possible et une de
mes inquiétudes
c'est que dans le projet de loi de
finances rectificative qui arrive on a
une détérioration de plus de de près de
24 milliards d'euros de déficit
supplémentaire donc honnêtement
aux et aujourd'hui quand on dit c'est la
fin du quoi qu'il en coûte depuis le
mois de janvier du socle le maire et
d'autres est annoncée oui mais moins 24
min mais peut-on aider les français qui
sont dans l'urgence sans aggraver le
déficit est bien sûr
mais en travaillant autrement c'est à
dire l'effet de la verticalité le refus
de travailler depuis quand le
gouvernement à travailler avec
l'ensemble des forces syndicales
que ce soit le monde de l'entreprise le
monde salarié quand est-ce qu'il a réuni
l'ensemble des grandes associations
d'élus de tout le territoire et 106
le concret il vient quand on associe
tous les décideurs au sein des décideurs
dans l'est ça donne quoi ça donne
composition ça veut dire quand on fait
des efforts les 10 millions de
professeurs les 10 millions de pauvres
je pense vous que moi il faut pas abuser
par du langage en disant moi je fais
vite et social de dlp la rallonge social
que je là elle est très loin de vous je
l'assuré parfaitement et ben alors donc
n'ayez surtout pas de jugement hâtif
maintenant c'est un parce que ça vous a
déjà joué d'état pour les femmes un peu
hâtive donc à bon les caves et boucané
ou savait très bien ce que je lui ai
donc m'intéresse donc nettement vous
savez très bien elle savait très bien
sait pas si si alors allez ça vous a
joué des tours
au conseil régional de bourgogne franche
comté donc tous ici voilà donc
objectivement c'est ça c'est ça se
travaille qu'on doit faire c'est de
remettre l'ensemble des forces et des
décideurs pas de propositions pour
trouver à proposer à sulmona
d'imposition
une seconde pour faire un gros plan sur
finalement ce qui a sûrement l'inflation
la plus ressentie par les dizaines de
millions de français qui n'ont pas
d'autre choix que de prendre leur
voiture c'est à dire les prix du
carburant alexandre pousse à vous allez
pouvoir nous nous rejoindre puisque sur
ces mesures on voit qu'il ya des
divisions entre sénateurs et députés
elle est effectivement thomas les
violons ne sont pas vraiment accordé sur
cette question du prix du carburant
entre les parlementaires un les
républicains alors justement on va
regarder ce que proposent les députés
les républicains dans ce débat sur le
pouvoir d'achat des français il y a
trois poko trois propositions
principales pour les députés aient l'air
une baisse de cotisations sur les
salaires pas de hausse de csg pour les
retraités et justement sur le prix de
l'essence les députés et leur souhaite
une baisse des taxes sur l'essence pour
atteindre un prix du litre à 1 aux 50 un
prix maximal bloqué à 1 euro 50 avec
cette idée d'une taxe flottante qui
abaisse quand le prix du carburant
augmente alors si cette mesure en
particulier que les sénateurs les
républicains ne trouvent pas pertinente
ils n'en veulent pas ils estiment que
c'est une baisse massive des taxes qui
est trop coûteuse qui arrose trop large
regardez ce que dit par exemple
christine lagarde vice présidente les
républicains elle la commission des
finances du sénat ça rejoint un peu ce
que vous dites jean françois husson il
faut des dispositifs ciblés les finances
publiques ne permettent plus de faire du
quoi qu'il en coûte nous dit christine
lagarde
les sénateurs républicains dans ce débat
sur le pouvoir d'achat vont faire leurs
propositions et pour eux il est hors de
question de creuser davantage les
déficits c'est ce que martelé hier soir
le président du groupe au sénat bruno
retailleau on va l'écouter pas de
nouvelles dépenses s'il n'y a pas de
nouvelles économies pas de nouveaux
chèques s'il n'y a pas des mesures
d'encouragement par le travail parce que
notre marque à nous c'est de penser que
le pouvoir d'achat
c'est d'abord du travail et non pas de
chèques des chèques sans provision fait
par l'état
voilà des sénateurs des républicains qui
sont vraiment dans la rigueur budgétaire
et c'est différences de point de vue
avec les députés l air et bien elle n'a
pas échappé au gouvernement on a vu
quand même qu'il y avait eu des prises
de position ici dlr différentes des
leurs à l'assemblée nationale dès bruno
retailleau par exemple sur des
propositions on a senti qu'il n'était
pas d'accord avec les propositions de
ses collègues parfois de l'assemblée
nationale c'est important pour la droite
de ne pas apparaître à diviser au moment
de négocier sur ce premier grand texte
du quinquennat face au camp d'emmanuel
macron alors les députés et les
sénateurs aient l'air ont décidé de
créer une instance de dialogue entre
leurs deux groupes parlementaires pour
pouvoir mieux accorder justement leurs
violons dans ce début de quinquennat
merci alexandre jean-françois ils sont
vous êtes plutôt olivier marleix coup
plutôt bruno otayo dans cette histoire
de deux prix de l'essence limite est
bloqué à 1 euro 50 j'ai déjà donné mon
point de vue limité à un euro cinquante
n'est aujourd'hui pas possible
travailler pour faire baisser le plus
possible le coût des carburants en lien
avec notamment les distributeurs avec
les grands groupes producteurs mais
aujourd'hui une partie du chemin a été
fait j'ai bien une partie je pense qu'il
faut peut-être aller plus loin je parle
là que ce n'est pas réaliste 1 euro 50
non non seulement non seulement ça n'est
pas réaliste mais je pense que ça n'est
pas réalisable il ya un certain nombre
de blocages d'ordre juridique et autres
mais est ce qu'il faut en permanence ne
restait que sur le prix des carburants
parce que ce prix des carburants on en
parlera peut-être moins quand il va
baisser mais il faut surtout faire
maintenant il est ressenti au 100 km et
vous surprendre les français il faut
aussi surtout travaillé pour ce qu'un
certain nombre de formes alternatives
j'ai bien de formes alternatives
parce que vous pouvez aider et faciliter
les déplacements en milieu urbain et
aider davantage c'est pour ça à cibler
davantage bien sûr bien sûr ce sont des
gens dont on entend votre argument on
les catégories sociales -
favorise proposer un euro 40 c'est
encore mieux ah c'est le niveau de
janvier 2010 les gens sont ces jours je
repose la question reste réaliste ou pas
aujourd'hui dans la situation on a
étudié cette mesure ça veut dire
effectivement proches voulaient dit tout
à l'heure ça veut dire prendre sur les
profits des grands géants des géants
pétroliers alors on peut dire on va
travailler avec eux et cela excuse moi
on travaille avec eux le gouvernement
nous dit ça
les sens et les rentes 2,2 euros vin et
je peux vous dire que les analystes en
économie disent que ça va se poursuivre
je prends donc on est appelé on n'est
pas prêt de s'en sortir et après juste
un mot là-dessus parce que c'est vrai
que là c'est l'urgence d'urgence après
il faut aussi songer à la manière dont
on pourra faire en sorte que les gens
aient bien et moins besoin de la voiture
petit à petit sur le long terme et ça ça
veut dire aussi bas par exemple
développer massivement les transports
publics les transports en communs
j'observe ferrand pas par exemple que
valérie pécresse ya quelques mois à
proposer au contraire de restreindre le
trafic et les fréquences ddm r je peux
vous dire que quand vous prenez le et
revers en période de covin notamment est
passé et c'est pas la panacée donc voilà
lé transport en pub public par exemple
la relocalisation des services publics
des collants c'est un euro carence
pardon j'y reviens à 940 mais qu'avant
oui je vis là dessus que c'est un euro
40 pour tout le monde oui vas-y ne cible
pas après il faudra évidemment des
mesures qui permettent de partager
massivement les richesses pour ça que
nous proposons en particulier la hausse
du smic à 1500 euros aujourd'hui on ne
vit pas dignement avec 1300 euros que
propose le gouvernement je vais vous
dire ce qu'ils proposent je m'arrêterai
là dessus la prime macron la fameuse
prime là et bien cette prime ils nous
disent on va augmenter le plafond
défiscalisées mais en l'occurrence
aujourd'hui à que 15% des salariés qui
bénéficient de cette prime macron
pourquoi pascal est facultative et
volontaire pour les entreprises en plus
ces primes c'est des primes défiscaliser
donc c'est moins de recettes pour l'état
et en plus ça n'est n'y a pas de
cotisations sociales versées donc c'est
un trou alors moi pour les caisses de
retraite et de sécurité la parole à eric
delannoy qu'on n'a pas entendu depuis un
moment mais d'abord ça rejoint ce que
vous dites notamment sur le fait de
demander finalement aux entreprises de
faire un effort ont écouté tout de suite
là la première ministre elisabeth
elisabeth bornes elle était hier soir
l'invité du 20 heures de tf1 elle dit en
quelque sorte aux patrons prenez vos
responsabilités et d'ailleurs le milieu
du travail olivier dussopt tu recevais
aujourd'hui les partenaires sociaux
syndicats patronat pour les encourager à
négocier des accords de branche c'est
comme ça qu'on dit eric delannoy est ce
que toutes les entreprises peuvent le
faire et ce qu'on a fait on est
effectivement ce que des rôles y trouver
tout à l'heure dans une situation où
elles ont
reconstitué leurs marges elles sont en
capacité de sa pose la question du
partage de la richesse au sein d'une
entreprise or il est vrai que les grâce
à des certaines mesures de productivité
notamment sur les impôts de production
et les marges des entreprises se sont
restaurés ont atteint des niveaux très
élevés c'est tout à fait vrai la
conséquence de ça quand même hein c'est
qu'on a atteint un niveau de recéder
desprats de déprécarisation de l'emploi
qu'on n'avait pas atteint depuis vingt
ans qu'on a atteint un taux d'emploi le
plus important qu'on est quasiment en
situation de baisse de plein emploi et
qu'on a fait une baisse de chômage une
baisse du chômage historique
fan liqing non non non laure fit excusez
moi mais le chômage
d'accord non il est arrivé car il sert à
5,1 millions 5 de chômeurs est
exactement pareil quand il est allé en
2022 dont on nous dit pas que le chômage
a baissé font peur à mettre en cause
tous les chiffres y compris l'insee qui
est allé sur les galères nourrit
évidemment chaises musicales non pas du
tout donc donc en fait il ya eu une
amélioration et on pourrait parler des
investissements étrangers enfin bon il
ya eu des ouvriers que cet argent n'a
pas forcément servi à enrichir les
patrons seraient sûrs que nous est ce
que j'entends dire qu'il ne veut pas
dire qu'il n'ya pas de problématique de
réparation de la richesse on est une des
raisons pour laquelle la prime macron
avaient été mises en place c'était
justement de permettre aux entreprises
ça n'a pas été suffisamment utilisé mais
c'est utilisent de plus en plus de
rémunérer les petits salaires puisque je
vous rappelle qu'elle est capé au niveau
de 3 fois le smic donc il est bien et
c'est une mesure ciblée que les
entreprises dans leurs responsabilités
celles qui le peuple puisse
effectivement dans un avec une
défiscalisation à une désocialisation
permettent de faire ça moi je voudrais
revenir quand même sur toujours ses
solutions faciles que tous les hommes
politiques prétendent ils auront il n'y
aura pas de deyne supplémentaires tant
qu'il n'y aura pas de recettes
supplémentaires
la phrase magie par excellence les elle
s'est tout de suite à faire des recettes
c'est demain le zamal points donc ça on
fait comment on fait alors que les elle
s'est tout de suite on le voit bien
distribution des chèques 1 euro 50 on va
y revenir dans un instant mais les
recettes l'émission se termine mais avec
les recettes ça nécessite des
investissements ça nécessite de la
formation ça nécessite ça ne peut se
faire qu'à moyen terme et donc il ya un
problème de temporalité que les
politiques ne prennent jamais en compte
ce qui fit que ça ne marche pas et si je
voulais conclure sur les problématiques
de 1 euro 40,1 euros 50 excitant à
regarder la chronique des prix de
l'essence et ça ça va pas plaire du tout
ce que je dirai la chronique des prix
les sens depuis 1970 à 2 euros par litre
le rapport du prix de l'essence par
rapport au smic etc et
est aujourd'hui un fait est favorable
par rapport aux allées aux années 1980
et voilà c'est choquant non mais elle
est bien sûr ces mois-là choquant parce
que vous comprenez avec la société
bien je vais vous dire c'est la réalité
des sifflets mais c'est ça les parodies
bhl parler français complaisante et de
malabo coeur mais c'est pas mieux il
faut expliquer les choses mais je suis
d'accord ces chiffres sont réels et ces
chiffres sont rien ou deux jours pas
raconter n'importe quoi sinon fait des
politiques qui ressemble à n'importe
quoi c'est ça c'est ça c'est le problème
de l'économiste en fait qui reste sur
ses statistiques sur ces graphiques et
qui ne voient pas non j'ai pas sur les
glandes donc sociale dramatique n'est
pas vrai sur la vie des gens mais il
sait pas ce qui s'est finalement bien ce
que vous dites non non c'est pas faux
c'est pas faux c'est l'art et la suite
moi je suis pas dans les chiffres et des
lettres dans les évolutions bien dommage
vraiment moi je suis dans des meetings
et dans le souci vient mais je dois
aussi france et je suis sur une
entreprise brésil et je n'ai pas dit
mais bien avec ces essais d'accord je ne
sais pas quels sont les résultats de
l'entreprise sait pas quelles sont les
régions où les chefs d'entreprise
en
plus la cabine conseil qui redistribue
l'intégralité de ses bénéfices
l'intégralité des bénéfices à des
associations d'égalité les champs bon
voilà donc avec ça aussi
d'accord maintenant ok mais moi je suis
pas anti entreprises
et tpe et les pme je dise le peuple sait
les grands actionnaires des entreprises
qui ont énormément augmenté leurs
revenus vous le savez très bien nous ne
sommes pas anti entreprises c'est le
problème c'est qu'elle si l'entreprise
qui en france que les entreprises
monsieur c'est aussi les salariés et là
je le vends salariés en moins en moins
dans la création de richesse des
entreprises et les détenteurs du capital
non plus en plus et ça ça c'est des
chiffres et vous les connaissez et puis
30 je suis là que la richesse des
entreprises va de plus en plus vers les
dividendes du canal rideau s'est alors
je suis d'accord et pourront peu
d'énervement j'aimerais vous entendre
sur cette question de la redistribution
de la richesse richesse au sein des
entreprises et finalement ce que
demandait elisabeth board prenez vos
responsabilités
mais moi j'ai aucun problème on va faire
des propositions pour favoriser
l'intéressement la participation des
salariés parce que je crois moi dans la
vie comme dans l'entreprise c'est
l'addition des forces c'est le collectif
qui permet de participer aux résultats
et de données mieux encore parce qu'il
ya de la mobilisation parce que vous on
vous aide pas ce qu on vous considère
parce qu'aujourd'hui on travaille
beaucoup d'entreprises les jeunes et les
moins jeunes sont attentifs à retrouver
redonner du sens à l'engagement dans
l'entreprise et hors de l'entreprise et
quand vous avez des personnels des
équipes qui ont la niaque qui sont en
bonne santé qui viennent dans de bonnes
conditions qui sont reconnus à la fois
reconnu humainement pas des gestes
élémentaires de respect de politesse
mais aussi par l'implication qui à
l'heure dans l'entreprise eh ben je vais
vous dire vous avez tu as qui sont comme
dans le sport on termine là dessus merci
beaucoup chacun eu la parole merci
d'avoir participé à ce débat